hi there everyone you might remember a
little while back we had a video with
the BBC micro and we interviewed a
physicist called dr. Richard Hill and he
showed us a game he made when he was a
boy he made it himself and even now all
these years later he's still tweaking
with it at the end of that video I asked
you guys the viewers if you'd been
working on anything recently or maybe
back in your earlier days of programming
I asked you to send it in so that Sean
who makes the computer file videos
behind the camera there so he could have
a look at it and you sent loads in like
I think it's well over a hundred have
been sent in and Sean's been wasting a
lot of time playing them when he should
be making computer for our videos we
don't know much about what you've sent
us you know if anyone's trying to taking
us for a ride and has sent us some
famous game from the 1990s we might not
know but we're doing our best to check
and if anyone's been naughty I'm sure
the rest of you will point out in the
comments as well so let's have a look
this has been sent in by I think it's
tosh i or tosh i i'm sorry i don't know
how to pronounce your name if we click
on the options you see here we can
adjust the level size field of view and
the sensitivity but let's go back and
have a look at the game because i'm sure
that's what you will want to say I'm
going to click play
giggle okay so pretty familiar Mario
there's that traditional kind of Mario
looking format for a 2-d game but we're
playing down here in a three-dimensional
world if I move the mouse I can change
the perspective and then here by using
the arrow keys I can go forward back
left right and spacebar to do Mario's
usual jumps and that's how you die I'm
not very good at this yet but I have my
home quite enjoying it
sometimes you're watching the 2d and
sometimes you're watching the
first-person and your brain kind of
fries and sometimes you go left and
right and steady forward and back but
anyway these are first world problems
aren't they oh I was playing it quite
well a few minutes ago when Shawn was on
the phone he is one of these baddies
well I don't know what these guys are
cold I'm sure you will do and you'll all
give me a hard time for not knowing
these little mushroom like men now I
didn't realize this but there is like a
whole kind of world of these Mario fan
made games look at this I'm gonna finish
this level very good very impressive
let's have a look at something else okay
now we have a contribution here from 18
year-old Andrew from Croatia who sent us
a bunch of programs we're just gonna
have a look at one of them and this is a
horror game that Sean tells me it's kind
of doom like what just made a sound
behind me
is this part of the game I hear a phone
ringing I don't know how I'm supposed to
oh hang on
look at this is doom like there's a
phone on the table
there's my feet I can look at my own
feet okay so now I'm using the arrow
keys to walk around and then a hands
come on the screen so I can answer the
phone presumably I'm gonna press that
weather forecast for tonight talk with a
chance of a dark with a chance of pain
I'm not sure I'm gonna go out in that
kind of weather but let's have a little
that foreboding warning oh look there's
my shadow being cast you can see that
the lamp is casting my own shadow onto
the onto the floor okay I've opened a
door Wow I had a scary monster jump out
at me from behind the door I think I
handled it well a lesser man may have
made a scary girly noise like ah but
that's exactly what I did and like most
of the time when I play these games I
spend most of the time just like staring
at walls like this but that's that's
more to do with my inaptitude than
anything obviously I could sit here and
play this all day and that would be a
little uninteresting for you but I am
impressed by this and for one person to
make this really impresses me I have to
look I wanna look behind another door I
think we should crack on and really I'm
worried I'm going to open another door
and get scared and make another really
embarrassing noise eighteen-year-old
Muhammad has sent us this one he's from
Birmingham just down the road from us
it's a Java game and it hasn't been
given a name yet so maybe you go I was
going to come up with a name for it and
I'm being told the reason it hasn't got
a name is there's not much to do but it
has got a multiplayer feature so I don't
know so I guess you can have multi
players with not much to do but uh let's
have a look I'm being asked to enter a
name I will enter my name Brady so there
we have a little character with my name
above it using the arrows I can move my
little brady around the screen it's very
cute this
kind of Brown case or container or box I
don't know how to interact with that
just yet when we asked everybody to send
in these games we should have also asked
them to send in instructions of how to
play the games we didn't think of that
look I'm going to walk I'm gonna walk
out this door and see if I can walk into
that water well you can look up to my
neck Wow I can remember a time not as
long ago as I'd like to admit when that
would have just blown me away
it could still kind of does I'm going to
try and switch on the music now that
Sean's recommendation you are about to
turn on music can be very loud do we do
it oh yeah that's adding a real a real
ambience a certain atmosphere to the
whole thing now it's completely changed
the game so does anyone come up with a
name for the game yet maybe Mohammed was
right you know maybe there's not a whole
lot to do it's still quite nice this box
seems to be the key to everything I must
know what's inside this box that's like
that it's like the case in Pulp Fiction
now I I have to know now we've got air
master from Karl in Sweden and Karl sent
us all the code and everything and
apparent that he's made everything here
that art the code of course the music
not the sound effects though I think
these friend made the sound effects for
him but uh Sean said it was one of his
favorites so let's have a look and see
what it's like I like the name
here we go that looks pretty cool seem
looking down into some kind of Canyon
here I'm going to choose stage 0
obviously written by a computer
programmer starting with 0 hello
computer file press space to continue
this level doesn't contain much but in
future it's going to be the tutorial
level be prepared for a big jump in
difficulty between this level and the
next level hint press you to level up
your weapon so if I press space I seem
to be able to fire these little oh yeah
did I die I died I don't know how I
don't know maybe it's just next next
level well Wow he wasn't kidding about a
jump a big difficulty it's insane
this is a quite cool what's that one
1942 it reminds me of it of that you
know real classic feel to it well well
done Carl I can see why you've managed
to distract Shawn with your game
okay oh okay yeah I've beefed up my
weapon of it now
ah so those are those are bad things I
saw these green orbs on the screen I
thought I've brilliant I'm going to grab
one of them turns out that was actually
enemy fire it's a learning curve this is
probably a good game to end this video
on because it's pretty cool and I think
we might be playing this one for a while
but if anyone else out there wants to
send us any programs they've made any
games anything they want us to have a
look at and feature here we'll happily
do more we've already got a load more
that Shawn's waiting his way through so
if you've already sent something we
haven't forgotten about it but if you've
been inspired by some of this and want
to send us something please do